thank you so I'm going to give roughly
the first half an hour of this
miniseries this today and I'm going to
lay the foundations talk about
introduction to Markov chains and their
properties and motivations and then I
will continue and introduce our first
technique for bounding the mixing time
so Markov chains we are to thank Andrey
Markov was born in the mid-1800s and he
came up with this idea of a random
process that were we have a set of
States and we are going to be in a state
and move to an random neighboring state
and the probability of moving the
distribution depends only on the state
that we are in and not on the history
that happened before so as an example
that all of us have seen before I guess
it's a simple random walk on a graph
here's my teeny-tiny lilica I start at a
vertex let's say that the vertex down
here and I choose one of its neighbors
at random so I choose this one and I
move there before I had probability of
1/4 to go to any of the neighboring
vertices now I have only two vertices to
choose from and therefore I'm moving to
either one of them with probability 1/2
so I go here and I kind of continue this
process so what it really means is that
I have a directed graph where the
weights on these edges have a
probability tell me the probability with
which I'm moving and actually I kind of
have this wonderful picture where the
bottom vertex has probability of one
force to move to either of the any of
the other vertices but the last vertex
has probability of 1/2 to choose the two
neighbors and so on and so forth
but now this gorgeous picture is
actually a little bit easier to see as a
matrix so this is really just the
adjacency matrix of this weighted graph
and now to simplify my phrasing I
labeled the vertices ABCDE and now each
row in the so-called transition matrix
is actually a probability distribution
so the numbers sum to one now this
allows me to actually
so move from random walks on graphs now
what happened was I changed the
one-fourth probability here to some kind
of arbitrary other numbers and that also
changes the transition matrix and this
is the formal definition of a discrete
Markov chain I'm going to for this part
of the talk I'm going to stay within
finite space and a finite oh and a
discrete time so I'm moving one time
step at a time
and a discrete Markov chain is a pair of
state space Omega and P where P is the
size of a megabyte size of Omega matrix
where it's rows are distributions and
here is an example now we are there are
all kinds of things that you can study
about the random walk you can study how
how long does it take to visit all of
the vertices you can study how long does
it take to come back to the starting
state and so on and so forth but we will
be interested in is this thing called a
mixing time and now what is a mixing
time Oh before I say that I'm going to
introduce this thing called stationary
distribution so a stationary
distribution is a distribution a vector
where I have the probability
distribution for every state phrase as a
vector and when I multiply that by the
transition matrix P I get the same
vector back so what I mean by that is
for a teeny tiny example here with three
vertices if I start at the bottom vertex
that's literally the vector 1 0 0 and
now after one step I'm going to be in
vertex B with probability 0.9 and in
vertex E with probability 0.1 which
corresponds to the distribution 0 for
probability of being in a 0.9 for
probability of being in B and 0.1 for
being in C so if you think about it
really what happened was we took the
starting distribution and we multiplied
it by the matrix P by the transition
matrix and if we do this P times we are
going to get the starting distribution
times P to the T and that's going to
lead actually
back one slide so now if we keep running
this Markov chain we are hopefully going
to converge to a distribution that would
be the stationary distribution once we
are there when we make one step if we
start in the distribution pile we might
make one step we will still be in the
distribution pipe so once we're there
you're there so now what happens is we
kind of want to see what kind of
conditions do we need to have a
stationary distribution and ideally to
have a unique stationary distribution
and that brings us to these two
properties we say that a Markov chain is
irreducible if in this graph of the
Markov chain the transition graph we
have a path from every vertex to of the
other vertex now I'm going to change my
terminology I'm going to call them
States from every state to every other
state so my example here is not
irreducible because once I get to be I'm
stuck there I have no means of actually
going to any other state but we can
verify the stationary distribution here
there is a stationary distribution and
it is 0 for probability of being in a 0
for c and 1 in B I once I am in that
distribution I stay there
but if I had another vertex let's call
it B on the other side here and I would
have some nonzero probability of getting
there from a or C or both and I wouldn't
be able to escape from there then I
would have two different stationary
distributions I would have one that
would have the full mass on B and then I
will have another one that would have
the full mass on D and I would be if I
if I run the Markov chain I do not know
which one I would converge to or any
combination of them so irreducibility is
a useful thing to have to as a path
towards having a single unique
stationary distribution and now a
periodicity is trying to avoid the
situation as I have here if I have to
stage and let's say I just go from A to
B and B to a well every other step I am
in a if I stay
Danae and so I will never converge so
there is a very simple way how to avoid
this situation we can simply kind of
slow down the chain by every other step
not really doing anything which
corresponds to having self loops of
probability 1/2 and what it really needs
is we are increasing the running time
the time it takes us to get to the
stationary distribution by a factor of
roughly 2 now the formal definition of a
periodicity is for every state when I
look at the path length of coming from
the state back to itself the greatest
common divisor of all these path lines
is supposed to be 1 and it turns out
that if we have a Markov chain that is
both irreducible and a periodic we call
it a gothic and an ergodic markov chain
has a unique stationary distribution
this brings us to the definition of the
mixing time and the mixing time is
really just a number of steps it takes
us to get to now the unique stationary
distribution from now on I'm living in a
world when I have regarding Markov
chains with a unique stationary
distribution and how many steps does it
take me to get there okay now I will
that would be too optimistic to think
that I get there I will get there within
and and kind of error parameter epsilon
so formally with the start in a state
acts by after T steps we are going to be
epsilon close to the stationary
distribution where this closeness is
distinct halt total variation distance
where we simply look at two
distributions and we measured their
distance now this is for discrete
distributions on what I mean on finite
States distributions
we simply sound across all of the states
and take the difference of the two
distribution values and we kind of
normalize by a factor of one half okay
so now what happens is we have an
ergodic Markov chain has a unique
stationary distribution meaning there is
this vector pi that if I multiply it by
P I get PI back well clearly this is an
eigenvector with eigenvalue 1 and
because b is a probabilistic matrix is a
stochastic matrix meaning every row sums
to 1 we can easily infer that all the
eigenvalues are actually an absolute
value upper bounded by 1 and then for
the next thing time depends on the so
called spectral gap which is the
difference between the first and the
second largest eigenvalue here's a
formal statement of this result but what
really happens is if I take whatever
starting distribution I have and I
decompose it into the eigenvectors then
in and I keep multiplying this by the
matrix P by making steps of the Markov
chain it's going to be the eigenvector
with eigenvalue 1 that is going to
dominate as I keep going because the
other eigenvalue
are smaller than one and those more than
one base to the number of steps is going
to get less and less important in the
result okay so now what happens next is
well this was all nice so we know that
we can't actually let me go back one
slide so the the mixing time can be
actually very nicely captured by this
spectral gap as a function of the
spectral gap so why do we even have
other techniques for bounding the mixing
time now this was all nice my baby
examples were teeny tiny 3 4 5 vertices
or spades but in reality would we often
have is exponential size state space so
for the exponential size size state
space here's an example this ties to
Leslie spots model that she introduced
in the in the talk just before lunch and
so what happens here is we have
colorings I'm going to do a special case
of the Potts model where I will work
only with valid colorings okay so my
input here is a graph and I have also a
set of colors Q and a coloring colors
vertices so that when I look at two
neighboring vertices they have to have
different colors okay so now I'd like to
somehow sample from the state space of
all valid colorings well what can I do I
can set up a Markov chain and I can do
so by for example by choosing a random
vertex and a random color and then if I
can recolor my vertex by that color I do
so so what that means is I choose this
vertex with color purple and none of the
neighbors are purple so I can any color
now next I choose this vertex with color
red I cannot recolor so I don't and I
just keep now it's yellow and so on and
so forth I can I can keep doing this but
we can notice if I give you this graph
with no edges the number of colors is
the number of colors that let me say it
again if I give you this graph with no
edges and none
of colorings is the number of colors
raised the number of vertices so
exponentially large that's kind of
unfortunate but that's fine and it is
also a periodic by it I mean the Markov
chain because I always have a chance to
select the vertex and then sell like its
current color or maybe the color of one
of its neighbors so it's clearly a
periodic so those that property is fine
now what happens for the irreducibility
it's kind of unfortunate that it's not
always irreducible namely if I have too
few colors in this case if I have only
three colors well I can happily choose
the rightmost vertex and recolor it but
that's it I don't I don't get to choose
anything else
so namely I can do this but I have no
means of actually using these steps of
the Markov chain to get to the coloring
that let's say swaps red and yellow so I
cannot get here
one thing the note is here is that I'm
no longer attempting to give you a
transition matrix I'm kind of giving it
implicitly because the transition matrix
can be potentially exponentially large
compared to the size of my input my
input here now is the graph itself okay
so in reality what's happening oh
actually before that if the number of
colors is large enough if it's bigger
than maximum degree plus one then I can
go from every coloring to every other
coloring because I have that one X extra
color that I can recolor to and I can I
can move so that makes the Markov chain
irreducible now to tie it back to the
picture with the transition matrix and
the corresponding transition graph I
tried I decreased my input size to just
four vertices so if I start with this
coloring on the little graph that I have
here I can move to these four
neighboring colorings and let's notice
that all of the probabilities of moving
are actually equal or a simply 1 over
the number of vertices times the number
of colors now one thing that I'm not
going to draw
are the self loops there is actually
quite big self loop which is equal to
one minus the number of neighbors times
this well one other thing to notice is
if I can go from one coloring to another
I can come back
so this Markov chain is so-called
symmetric and it's the definition of
symmetric Markov chains when we have
going from any state X so any state Y we
have the same probability of coming back
now it turns out actually let me let me
try to draw more of the transition graph
this is where I gave up and so what
really happens is if we have a symmetric
Markov chain and it's a gothic so we
have a unique stationary distribution
now we can simply plug in the uniform
stationary distribution meaning every
coloring is equally likely we can plug
it in into the pi times P equals pi
equation we verify that it's true based
on the symmetry and we have it so for a
symmetric markov chain unique state
unique uniform stationary distribution
if the Markov chain is ergodic
ok so that brings us to a more general
concept a Markov chain is said to be
reversible if there is a distribution PI
such that this is a more general
statement of symmetry now I don't have
just P XY equal to py X but I'm if I
start in the state X and I move to Y I
get the same probability as if starting
in Y and moving from Y to X ok this
condition is also called the detailed
balanced condition and if we have such a
condition sorry we will see that the
distribution pipe is stationary again
just by plugging it into the PI times
because PI equation ok so now we can
actually use this in a meaningful way
and suppose that we want to sample from
some kind of target distribution ok I'm
going to college PI now how do we
actually go about it this is the Metro
police
the other there is a generalization of
it that goes by the name of metropoliz
hasting I'm just going to the metropoliz
here so what I do is I started with a
symmetric regarding Markov chain so
therefore I have a uniform unique
uniform stationary distribution and now
instead of using the original
probability of moving I'm going to
modify it a little bit so that I get the
stationary distribution that I want not
the uniform but my PI so what I'm going
to do I'm going to simply adjust the
original probability by PI Y over PI X
when I'm going to go from X to Y namely
or if it is bigger than 1 then I'm kind
of lower of taking one instead so what's
happening is if here am the state acts
and I want to go to state why I look at
state Y and I say hey are you more
likely than I am and it says yes I am
well then I go there Eve on the other
hand it's less likely then I'm kind of
hesitating a little bit okay I'll go
with some probability okay and so as an
example let's go back to the colorings
but now suppose that I do not want the
sample from the colorings uniformly at
random I do not want all colorings to be
equally likely but what I want I want
probability distribution I completely
made this up this is not a probability
distribution that people are really
interested I suppose it's not the Potts
model but just some kind of an example
to give us an idea about what's going on
so if I want to have my stationary
distribution a probability of being in X
to be proportional to some constant
alpha to the number of red vertices in
ax and alpha is bigger than one so it
would be giving preference the
configurations the colorings that have
more red vertices would be more likely
so what I can do or just like before I
can choose a random vertex D and the
random color C now if I can recolor V by
C well then I'm going to now do the
additional adjustment so if I would
increase or keep the same number of red
colors then I would simply go any color
my vertex if on the other hand the
number of red colors would decrease
meaning I would be Li coloring from red
pen on red then I do so only with
probability one over alpha okay
now one thing that I wanted to point out
is my proportionality of the
distribution well if I were to actually
describe this actual probability what I
would do is my probability in the
stationary distribution of a state of a
coloring X is equal to alpha to the
number of red vertices in X but now I
have to normalize by the partition
function by the summation across all
colorings of alpha to the number of red
vertices in X the good news is well
that's usually very very difficult to
compute quantity the good news is I
don't need that because those terms
would cancel out in this ratio so this
is how to design a Markov chain with a
target distribution and oh here's just a
few pictures that demonstrate what's
happening if I'm going from this yellow
to blue I just go if I'm going from red
to yellow to that I just go but if I'm
going from red to yellow then I do so
only with probability 1 over alpha but
that's not quite true because I really
do it with probability 1 over n heel
alpha because I have the original
probability of moving okay so now
you have the B prime XY on multiplying
the 1 as well right yeah yeah I'm kind
of cheating here but this is doing it's
really one over and Q probability yeah
so 1 over NQ is everywhere ok so now how
does this all actually relate to
counting well actually even before that
the colorings Markov chain that
something that Naya will analyze it's
mixing time off tomorrow on Tuesday and
I will then talk about this problem on
Wednesday but let's first see why do we
even care what do we want to do with
this Markov chains well of course we can
just use them to sample from a
distribution that we want but we can
also use them for something else and
that's this relation to counting so if I
give you an undirected graph a matching
is simply a set of edges that do not
share any vertices as we've seen in
chingy's talk this morning so here I
have a matching here I have another
matching and this matching is perfect
because all of the vertices have been
adjacent matching edge now what we know
about matching is that they've been
studied very significantly and we know
how to find a maximum or the existence
of a perfect matching or even find a
perfect matching in polynomial time for
any graph but counting them is sharpy
complete as was mentioned this morning
so we are kind of in a in a tricky
situation
can we actually estimate this number of
perfect matchings even though this
problem is sharp it complete and what we
are going to do we are going to do an F
cross as Leslie introduced in her talk
we are going to go to approximate
counting of all perfect matchings but
actually I'm going to simplify my life a
little bit I'm going to go to the
problem of counting all matchings
instead of perfect matchings for now and
all matching and that problem is also
known to be
be complete so it's also unlikely to get
a deterministic algorithm for that okay
so suppose that we know how to sample a
random matching okay so here's my bra
and I'm going to take an arbitrary edge
here's my edge E and I'm going to use
the sampling to figure out how likely it
is to see this matching this edge in a
random matching actually I'm going to do
the opposite I'm going to see how likely
it is to not see the edge in a random
matching so I'm going to take a random
matching my edge is out and then the
matching it's in random matching it's in
now it's out so I'm going to estimate
the following ratio the number of
matchings without the edge a over the
total number of matchings and i can do
that by setting up an estimate for an
indicator random variable that is equal
to 1 if my matching my random matching
does not contain the edge e now we can
observe that this random variable the
expected value is between 1 half and 1
which is important because if it was too
tiny that we would need way too many
samples to actually get to the expected
value to be able to estimate reasonably
but now we are between 1/2 and 1 and one
of these inner part is super easy to see
obviously the number of matching without
it is upper bounded by the total number
of matching so we have less than or
equal to 1 but also the other one is
easy to see because for every matching
that contains the edge e we can take it
out and we have a matching that does not
contain E and this map is actually
injected into from the set of matches
that contained H e to the set of matches
that do not contain E and as such the
matchings that do not contain either at
least half of them when we look at the
total set of all matches so we have
enough if we have a lower bound of 1/2
now so what we wanted to estimate was
the number of matchings without the edge
e over the number of matchings
okay and we can notice that this is
actually the number of matchings in the
original graph G which now I'm going to
call G zero and the number of matchings
without any in the original graph the
same as the number of matchings in a
graph G one where I take the original
graph G and I take the edge it out okay
so in other words my G zero is the
original graph and my G one is the one
that I take the edge e out so the ratio
that I'm estimating with my sampler is
really just a ratio of these two
matching all of the matching in g1 over
all of the matchings in G zero so now
what this is oh okay the trick
continuous well now I can I can have
this fun again right so in G 1 I can now
take an edge let me go back so this was
G 1 now I can take an edge I think I
took this one and I'll estimate how
likely it is to not be in a random
matching in G 1 right which will mean
that I will have an estimate for the
number of matching in the graph where I
take this edge out it to out over the
number of matchings
in the graph G 1 and I can keep doing
this
so what I'll do is G 2 is now the graph
with two edges removed G 3 with three
edges removed and so on and so forth all
the way until I remove all of them ok
and now what happens is these indicator
random variables when I look at their
their expectation I was just computing
these kind of ratios number of matching
is in G one over number of matchings in
G zero so a lot of things happen here on
the slide but not really just notation
so the original random variable was
estimating the number of matchings in G
1 over G zero then I can do the same
thing for the next edge and estimate the
number of matching Xin Jie 2 over a
number of match
in g1 and so on and so forth and take
the product of all of the expected
estimates of the expected values so what
really happens here this is a
telescoping product you can see that ng
one cancels and g1 and so on and so
forth and I'm left with just a ratio of
the number of matchings in the last
graph the one that doesn't have any
edges over the number of matchings in
the first graph but in the last curve I
have just one at one matching the one
that is empty and then in the original
graph I have that that's the denominator
this part of a concept is called cell
reducibility where we get to use the
same idea on it on a smaller instance of
the same problem okay so now what the
dealing is is I learn all of these
estimators I use the sampling to
estimate each of these ratios and so I
have M where m is the number of edges
and ratios and then what this brings me
to is I'm going to go ahead oh I have
some definitions here but Leslie
convenient to introduce the fully
polynomial randomized approximation
scheme for me what really means I am
going to find the answer to a counting
problem and I have an error tolerance
Epsilon and I want to produce an answer
within 1 plus minus X epsilon factor of
the true answer and I want to do so with
probability at least 3/4 any time
polynomial in input size and 1 over
Epsilon and I have a similar concept for
an almost uniform sampler where I want I
want to be able to sample from the
uniform distribution between some kind
of error tolerance of Delta and my
running time should be polynomial in the
input size and logarithm of 1 over Delta
so the previous the the telescoping
product of ratios with the Lily said was
if we can sample
we can pound and the actual number of
samples that we needed we would need to
do some calculation but we had M ratios
the number of edges is M and ratios we
would kind of need to estimate each one
of them within epsilon over m so that
when we multiply all of them together we
have an error of Epsilon and so it comes
to about n over epsilon square samples
per ratio times and ratios and then this
is the running time of the sampler
itself so what it comes to comes to is
we want to design a way of sampling
random matchings and that's where Markov
chain design comes in and the better
mixing time we get the better running
time of the F cross and I think this is
the end of my half
hey thanks Evo not for setting stuff up
for me
so when I talked about why it might be
useful to get estimates on the mixing
time of the Markov chain and what I'll
be talking about is a specific kind of
probabilistic technique for doing this
so so roughly maybe you could divide the
techniques for bounding the mixing time
of a Markov chain into oops sorry into
probabilistic techniques which include
things like coupling strong stationary
times and coupling from the past and
techniques which work directly with the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions so as you
saw if want to mention that the mixing
time can be related to the spectral gap
of the transition matrix and this is
often done through functional and ease
of parametric inequalities so what I'll
be talking about is coupling and showing
you several examples and and how to use
coupling to bound the mixing time and
fairly comprehensive accounts of these
techniques and applications can be found
in these books by 11:00 Paris and Wilmer
and by Aldous and Phil okay so so today
I'll be talking about what it means to a
couple distributions and what it means
to a couple to Markov chains and
tomorrow I'll be talking about some more
advanced coupling techniques like path
coupling and
passed for exact sampling so so to
understand coupling let's first look at
the total variation distance between two
distributions so I've got here mu and nu
there are probability measures on some
measurable space and I'm going to give
you a different different definition of
the total variation distance this is the
supremum over all a's which are in your
Sigma field F of the difference between
the the measures on that set okay now
we'll focus in this tutorial on spaces
Omega which are finite and we'll think
of the Sigma field as just all the
subsets of the space to the Omega so
it's so it's easiest may be to
understand total variation distance in a
picture so let's say we've got our two
distributions mu this yellow one and
knew this blue one and you see that
there's some portion here which which
they overlap on so so the first claim is
that the total variation distance this
definition that I gave you which in the
finite case just reduces to the maximum
over all subsets of Omega of the
difference oops of the difference
between the two distributions on the set
and we claim that that's in fact equal
to half of the l1 norm as well so so
let's let's see that a little bit so if
you if you think about the l1 norm you
see that the part where the overlap is
this probability which I've called gamma
and since the area under both of these
distributions is 1 so alpha should be
equal to 1 minus gamma and beta should
be equal to 1 minus gamma right and this
in
is actually alpha and therefore it's
also equal to beta on the other hand
intuitively you could think about what
would be the set which maximizes new of
a minus new of a and I won't go into the
proof but intuitively it's it's the set
here that that goes from here to here
where new dominates new as well as its
complement so all right so maybe maybe
let me write down these four for
reference
just in case you haven't seen these
before it's kind of helpful to have them
on hand okay so so what is a coupling so
suppose I have two distributions mu and
nu on the same measurable space then a
coupling of mu and nu is a pair of
random variables x and y which you can
think of as being defined on the product
space with the product sigma field so
that the marginals coincide meaning if
you look individually at the
probabilities that X is in some set a
then that's equal to MU of a and the
probability that Y is in a is equal to
nu of a for every a and F why do you
need the same space why do I need the
same space so do you mean why is why is
the coupling itself defined on the same
space mu and nu can be defined they can
be yes they can be but but let me let me
here just stick to the same space in
general they can be so you can see that
one one easy way to define a coupling
would be simply to take independent
variables x and y and let X be
distributed according to mu and let Y be
distributed according to new and that
would constitute a valid coupling but
the whole sort of point is to define x
and y jointly on Omega cross Omega 2 in
order to sort of pull something more out
of that see we'll see that in a second
okay so so let's just look at an example
of a coupling and
see see why it might be useful for
proving things so I suppose that I have
two distributions one of them is
Bernoulli P so think of it as
corresponding to a coin which comes up
heads with probability P and nu is a
Bernoulli curette distribution and the
probability of coming up heads is Q
which is bigger than P okay and suppose
that H mu of n correspond is equal to
the number of heads in n tosses and H nu
of n is the number of heads in n tosses
for the second coin okay so since you're
more likely to come up heads when you're
distributed like new you might expect
that the chance of having at least K or
greater than K heads in n tosses is more
for the second coin than for the first
coin and how would you prove such a
thing so maybe you could go and you know
use the binomial theorem and calculate
what these what these probabilities are
but that seems a lot of work so so we'll
see you know how to use coupling to to
show this quite easily
okay so what we're going to do is 4i
between 1 and n construct a coupling of
mu and nu which I'll call X I Y I and X
I Y I is going to be independent for
different eyes so X I and why I will
simulate a pair of coupled coins which
individually will have the distributions
mu and nu and and we'll see what we get
out of that so how could you construct
such a coupling so let's do the
following let's let X I be distributed
according to mu so just it's just like a
coin which comes up heads with
probability P and we said why I as
follows if X I happens to come up 1 then
we said X I to be 1 and if X I comes up
0 then remember that Y I has to be
distributed like new so it's probability
of coming up
q which is bigger than P so I have some
probability left over so what I'm going
to do is you know when X I comes up zero
I said why I to be one with a certain
probability and zero otherwise and we
can sort of do the calculation and see
that because we said Y I to be one in
this case we're forced to have this
value in order for this to be a coupling
because what is the probability that Y I
is equal to 1 this is P times 1 plus 1
minus P times something and this must be
equal to Q so that X must be this Q
minus P divided by 1 minus P all right
so so now the nice thing to notice about
this coupling is that whenever X I is 1
then Y I is necessarily 1 and therefore
X I is less than or equal to Y I and
also that means that the sum of x i's is
less than or equal to the sum of Y eyes
and since the sum of the x i's is
distributed exactly like the number of
heads and n tosses for the first coin
and similarly for the sum of Y eyes so
this tells us that if the sum of X eyes
was greater than K then the sum of Y
eyes would be greater than K all right
so so so that's how you couple
distributions and now the interesting
thing is that you can use couplings to
get yet another definition of the total
variation distance and this is what will
be useful in bounding the mixing time
eventually ok so so here's here's the
lemma that we'll use
suppose that mu and nu or distributions
on Omega then the total variation
distance is bounded by the infimum over
all possible couplings of mu and nu of
the probability under that coupling that
x is not equal to y so we've already
seen two definitions of the total
variation just
and this one is saying well it's not
saying yet but in fact this inequality
is inequality and you can show that
there is a coupling which which achieves
the total variation distance so this is
saying that another way to view total
variation distance is another way to
view tonal variation distance is you
know how closely you can get two random
variables to have the right
distributions mu and nu and have them be
close okay so so this is the inequality
that's going to be important for us that
you can bound the distance by the
probability of any coupling not being
equal so let's see how that follows so
I'm going to use this definition of the
total variation distance and I notice
that if I take any coupling X Y and any
set in Omega then mu of a minus nu of a
is because X and X Y is a coupling it's
just the probability that X is an a
minus the probability that Y is an A and
now it's just a set inequality to show
that this is bounded by the probability
that X is an a and at the same time Y is
an A and if X is in a and Y is not an a
then that means X is not equal to Y
necessarily and so this is bounded by
this probability and by exactly the same
argument new of a minus mu of a is
bounded by the probability of the
coupling not being equal and therefore
what you get using this definition is
that the total variation distance can be
bounded by the probability of X not
being equal to Y and since we showed it
for an arbitrary coupling an arbitrary
you said we're done okay so so this is
going to be useful because remember that
in order to balance the mixing
time of a Markov chain we'd like to
bound the total variation distance
between the T step distribution and the
stationary distribution so what we'd
like to do is construct couplings of
Markov chains where the probability of
the couplings not being equal will bound
the total variation okay so so so let me
let me skip this bit which says that in
fact there is a coupling which achieves
the total variation distance we're not
going to use it at all and instead move
on to the definition of a coupling of
Markov chains okay so suppose you have
two Markov chains
with transition matrix P then a coupling
sorry suppose you have a Markov chain
with transition matrix P then a coupling
is a process XT and YT so that both the
processes XT and YT are themselves
Markov chains with transition matrix P
okay so so we'll see in a second how you
can bound the total variation distance
to stationarity by the coupling as well
as how you would construct a coupling of
a Markov chain in a in a specific
example but let me just mention that
this this particular technique has been
used to bound the rate of convergence to
stationarity for a large number of
combinatorial and statistical physical
problems as well as shufflings of cards
and so on and here here's just I guess a
small sample of some of the works that
have done this some of the earlier works
that that did this okay so so let's see
you again like a very simple example of
a coupling of two Markov chains and see
how it can be useful for
moving sort of domination like we did
before so let's say you have a simple
random walk so the simple random walk on
the interval 0 through n is the Markov
chain which tries to move up with
probability 1/2 and down with
probability 1/2 and if it tries to move
out of the interval then it just stays
where it is so your your Markov chain
looks something like this ok all right
so now it's reasonable to think that if
you had two copies of the Markov chain
one of which was started at a point X
which is less than or equal to a point Y
then the probability that starting from
X you reach 0 in T steps that should be
bigger than or equal to the probability
of reaching 0 from Y and T steps right
and we'll try to prove this using
coupling so here is a coupling of the
two markov chains one of which is
started at X and one of it just started
at Y so I'll call this coupling XT YT
and what I'm going to do is couple the T
step distributions so this is the
distribution over States after T steps
when you start at X and this is the
distribution after T steps when you
started why I start by setting X 0 and y
0 respectively to X&Y and then I take a
sequence of iid bernoulli's plus minus 1
valued b1 b2 etc okay and I use these
Bernoulli's to perform the random walk
and I do it in the following coupled
fashion so at the eyuth step i attempt
to add the Bernoulli be i to both X I
minus 1 and y i minus 1 and if that
causes me to move out of the interval I
just stay where I am
in each of those chains okay so here's
an example where that's happening so in
the first step I subtract one from both
both processes and then you see that in
the next three steps I add one here but
I add one I add one and then I'm at the
end of the interval and I cannot add one
so I just stay where I am in the next
step so I do this and what you can argue
or maybe what you can see from the
picture already is that in this coupling
the yellow walk will always stay greater
than or equal to the green walk and they
will meet if they meet they will meet
either at one end of the interval or the
other and once they meet they will stay
together because you're adding or
subtracting the same thing to both okay
so the important thing is going to be
that XT is bounded by YT and so that
immediately gives us that the
probability that Y reaches T in that Y
reaches 0 and T steps is the probability
that Y T is 0 but when YT is 0 for
example here that forces XT to be 0 so
that's bounded by the probability that
XT is 0 and that that gives us the
inequality that we want so all right so
this was a coupling of Markov chains but
maybe not a very common at Oriel one
like the ones that if what I was talking
about oh and here's a note that if you
have a coupling of two markov chains you
can always modify it so that once the
chains meet they stay together
thereafter because you can always take
your coupling and say after they meet
just do the same thing in both and we'll
assume that this that this is the case
for the couple things we look at
okay so how do you use coupling to bound
the distance to stationarity so let's
define DT to be the distance the total
variation distance to stationarity of
the T step distribution and D bar T is
going to be the total variation distance
between the T step distributions when
you start at two different points x and
y two different states x and y and you
can show that DT is in fact closely
related to D bar T and in particular
we'll use the inequality that DT is
bounded by D bar T okay and then the
mixing time recall is the the time to
get within epsilon stage epsilon of
total variation distance to stationarity
and a remark that will also work with
just the the time to get within one
quarter of stationarity because you can
argue that you only pay logarithmically
in order to scale the mixing the the
distance to stationarity okay so with
those definitions in hand here's here's
the theorem so suppose that X T YT is a
coupling of a Markov chain with
transition matrix P where you're
starting at X in one chain and at Y in
the other chain and suppose that tau
star is the first time that they meet
then this distance D bar T is bounded by
the probability that you haven't met by
time T so here's the proof it's fairly
simple so remember we had I meant to
write it down but I forgot of course we
had this lemma which said that the total
variation distance between two
distributions is less than or equal to
over couplings of the probability that X
is not equal to Y so let's use this for
the coupling of the T step distributions
so that tells us that this distance D
bar T is bounded by the probability that
the couplings are not equal at time T
but that is just the probability that by
time T you have not coupled and here's a
quick corollary which gives you a bound
on the mixing time so we claim that the
time to get within a quarter of total
variation distance can be bounded by
four times the maximum over pairs of
starting points x and y of the expected
time to couple so how does that go
well DT is upper bounded by D bar T and
we just showed that that's bounded by
the probability of not having coupled by
time T and Markov inequality then gives
you that that's bounded by the expected
time to couple divided by T so if you
have time T which is larger than four
times this maximum then you would be
within 1/4 little variation distance
okay okay so good five minutes so I
wanted to show you one application
doesn't that mean you have to actually I
mean if you actually want to bump the
mixing time like that you have to find
the worst x and y right that's right
yeah so we're gonna we're gonna see how
you do that so a lot of times what you
end up doing is arguing that this
expected time to couple is bounded for
arbitrary parents X Y and we'll see an
example of that but there are there are
also techniques that bubbly and dire
developed would say that by putting sort
of an appropriate metric on your space
of
configurations it's enough to just bound
it's enough to just consider pairs of
X&Y that are adjacent to each other so
that simplifies things a lot but yeah so
so here's here's a here's the Markov
chain this the state space is decks of
cards with N and cards and the Markov
chain that we look at shuffles these
cards in the following way so at every
step T you choose a card XT and an
independent position YT between 1 and n
uniformly so for example you're suppose
your deck is currently Sigma T and you
chose the card 3 to the X T and you
chose the position 4 to be Y T then that
corresponds to these two cards and what
the Markov chain does is is is it
exchanges these two parts so it's
shuffling by random transpositions and
once you do that you end up at this
configuration Sigma of T plus 1 and if
you you can show using the detail
balanced equation that if I went through
that the stationary distribution will be
uniform over the set of permutations so
let's construct a coupling and try to
analyze it so here's the coupling we
have two arbitrary decks or States
I'll call at time T so one is called
Sigma T and the other is called Sigma
prime T and these two are arbitrary like
Marshall pointed out you have to show a
bound on the expected time to couple for
arbitrary States ok and then the
coupling will be as follows you're going
to choose a card XT and an independent
position YT as before and then use XT
and YT to update both Sigma T and Sigma
T prime together now in order to bound
the expected coupling time we're going
to have sort of a proxy variable that we
look at for which which will tell us we
haven't
a couple so far so so this is going to
be empty the number of cards which are
in the same position in your two decks
so when you've coupled another number of
cards in the same position should be N
and it will start off at some arbitrary
value okay so so now we do a little bit
of case analysis and we find the
following so let's suppose that you
chose XT to be in the same position
meaning that you chose card eight and it
happens to be in the same position then
you look at YT and two things can happen
either the card at YT is the same or not
so if it's the same and you exchange a
de and Q in both then your number of
matched cards does not change or it
could have happened may be that you
chose YT to be this position and then
you notice that the match just moves
over so again it doesn't change in this
case the number of matched cards you
have a second case where you could have
XT in different positions and the card
add YT is the same so if we think about
what happens here when you exchange
these two you're going to mess up the
match between the queues but now you'll
create a match between the eights and so
you will have no net change in the
number of matched cards and then case
three is kind of where something
interesting happens so this is the case
when XT is in different positions but
the card at YT is not the same so now a
couple of different things can happen so
if you look at this first example we're
going to exchange the a with the three
here and the eight here and when we do
that you see that the eight will go and
sit opposite the Q and the three will go
and sit opposite this Q and you'll
create a match out of the eight here
okay so you'll create one extra match
like this but it could have happened it
could have happened to be the case that
the card opposite the a was the one that
you were exchanging it with and in that
case you'll create an extra
match when you when you exchange these
two because you would get eight over
here which would match with this and you
would get an ace here and an ace here
and a 3 here okay so that so then MT
would go up by two and then if it
happens that that the card opposite to
the ace is you know matching in in both
cases with the one you're exchanging
then you could go up by three but all in
all what you have is that MT plus one is
bigger than MT and this covers all the
cases okay so so that's enough for us to
bound the expected time to couple so
here's the the preposition suppose that
tau star is the first time that MT is
equal to n so all the cards are matched
then the claim is that for any x and y
the time decouple is bounded by some
constant times n square and that implies
by the result on the mixing time that we
showed earlier that the mixing time is
of order n square okay so how do we show
this bound on the expected time to
couple so you can write down the
expected time to couple as a sum tau 1
plus tau 2 etc where tau I will be the
number of steps you take to increase MT
from I minus 1 to I so what is the
probability of increasing MT given that
it's I so we saw in the case analysis
that what you need to do is choose XT to
be in different positions and have the
cards at YT be different and the
probability of that happening is that
you choose so n minus I is the number of
unmatched cards so you choose you know
with probability n minus I over N XT and
then you choose the other unmatched a
pair of cards with this probability as
well and you can check that if you
happen to choose the same card then
still all works out that is a case ok so
so that's the probability that you end
up in
creasing so it means that that that you
weight a geometric amount of time with
this success probability so the expected
time to increase would be the inverse of
that and square over this and so if you
sum up all of these and take expectation
you get that the expected time the
couple is bounded by n square times this
quantity which can be bounded by a
constant all right so so I'll stop there